good morning believe nation today's
message is be restless over you Nikesh
Arora in my life I have always been
Restless I've never been able to settle
with status quo every time I felt that
life is getting boring life of getting
an exciting I decided to pick up and
move and do something different and I've
actually never had a plan
so people I go speak at places people
ask me so did you have all this chart it
out and I've never had a plan chart it
out I still don't know what's going to
happen tomorrow as long as you're happy
as long as you feel you're making a
difference as long as you feel that that
your restlessness is getting satisfied
which again is an oxymoron because once
your restlessness gets satisfied you're
no longer restless and you have to be
restless again
so I always tried to be restless always
try to do something different I grew up
in this country I can ended up being an
engineer decided I didn't wanna lose
efforts along which was a bad choice now
that in Silicon Valley I realized I
should have stuck to those guns but
anyway decided to become a business
person and decided to go to business
school in the US I landed there with two
suitcases and a pair of white socks
which I still remember fondly but that's
part of my romanticizing again so from
there on you know I graduated business
school again I went to work in the
financial industry when I was applying
for jobs I was told that you don't have
enough finance so since I from then I
went to go to more degrees in finance so
every time I felt that I I've been
challenged I've gone and picked up my
bags and done something different so I
got bored in Boston I picked up the same
two bags and went to Germany and decided
to work in Germany where I didn't speak
over the German and the average peer
group was 50 years old right so there
are many moments in our lives when we
come to that point to realize what would
have happened if I had gone the other
way or what is the doors had shut sooner
before you walked into the train and you
can go back and think about those
moments in life but it's not about those
moments is about the moments when you
actually walk through the door I think
entrepreneurs in general are pretty
restless we are restless Bunch we are
not satisfied with the status quo we
want to change the way things are done
you know we don't like our boss we don't
like our job we don't like the industry
are in and instead of just complaining
what do we do we make a change we do our
own thing you want to be the change that
we want to see in the world right that's
what we as entrepreneurs do and it's why
I believe every major problem in the
world will be solved not by corporations
not by charities - by entrepreneurs I
think we hold the secret to every
positive change it is coming in a big
way and so I think restlessness helps us
in two major ways and one is kind of
hidden so the first is the decision to
start right a lot of people have ideas a
lot of people want to start a business
not everybody does because they're not
restless enough they don't want it badly
enough right they're safe they're secure
sure they'd like to have more money sure
that I have a bigger impact but they
have a nice job you're making a nice
money you know you have commitments and
responsibilities and people who look
after you know you can't afford to go
out and do that thing
you're not restless enough right too
safe in your environment so you don't
ever do anything and that's 90 percent
of America right you wake up to a job
that you hate and so the restlessness in
entrepreneurs allows us to get started
to pursue our vision to build a company
to solve a problem to be fulfilled to
help customers that's what we do the
second part of restlessness though I
think is kind of a silent killer for a
lot of entrepreneurs what happens in a
lot of companies is we get bored of our
company not something a lot of people
talk about but it happens a lot happens
to a lot of entrepreneurs they get bored
they get tired why don't you leave that
job to start your company because it was
boring because you weren't learning
because we weren't growing because you
weren't having impact that you wanted to
have and what ends up happening is at
the start of the company started your
new business everything is what you want
to do start building your vision up and
then somewhere along the line you have
customers and there's expectations and
you found the things that will make you
successful and so you keep doing those
things right you find the path of
success keep doing that thing repeat
rinse and repeat rinse repeat rinse
repeat make more right go go go
challenges for someone who's Restless
what happens when you're just copied and
pasted in a copy
paste and copy and paste you copy and
paste
you get bored you want to do the same
thing all this why you left your job you
don't want to do the same thing over and
over and over and over and over and over
and over again at infinitum right you
don't want to do that and not enough
entrepreneurs recognize that and so they
end up in a spot where they hate their
business where they just bought
themselves a job understand I don't want
to do this anymore I'm going to start
something new I want to sell this
business on and move on to something
else where the real trick to solving
this problem is constant and
never-ending restlessness and
improvement in your business once you
find what made you successful keep doing
that and then try to beat it as you
evolve and change and grow as a human
being
guess what you have to bring that to
your business if you are evolving and
changing and growing and your business
is staying the same and doing always the
same thing you are going to get bored
there'll be a point where you've grown
so much that you don't recognize your
business at all you don't want to be
there anymore so you need to be
constantly introducing restlessness into
your business as you grow as you get new
ideas as you evolve you need to bring
that to your business immediately so
that line doesn't get too far apart so
that you never get bored of your
business my company has changed a lot
since I first started there's still been
that passion for helping entrepreneurs
but the execution has changed a lot I
never thought it'd be doing YouTube I
never wanted to write a book I never
thought it'd be working with big brands
and never thought people would offer me
spots on their board of directors and
ever thought I'd be investing in the
company there's none of this ever part
of my plan when I started but if all I
did was what I was doing when I started
I would hate my comforter right now you
need to evolve your business as you
evolve yourself continue to be restless
so the question today is I'm curious
what are you Restless about right now
leaving the comments below to Precure to
find that I also want to give a quick
shout out to Rick Vasquez Rick thank you
so much for picking up a copy of my book
here one word really really really means
a lot to me man I appreciate the support
I hope you're enjoying the breeze so
thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word
is much love and I'll see you again
tomorrow morning for another shot events
press
why do you still care enough to keep
your at a point in your life where you
could go back you could do your month in
Vegas and Florence Henderson could open
up and you could go and hit a couple of
balls and then some pinball why do you
still care so much well I'm not
comparing myself to any of these people
believe me but you wouldn't say to
Picasso
why are you got to put those brushes
down they read in a canvas you've done
it is not you I'm an entertainer first
and foremost but there's art involved
here and an artist has an obligation to
be on route to be going somewhere
there's a journey involved here and you
don't know where it is and that's the
fun so you're always going to be seeking
and looking and going and trying to
challenge yourself so without sitting
around thinking of that a lot it drives
you in it and it keeps you trying to be
fresh trying to be new trying to call on
yourself calling yourself a little more
it seems like you're your man of
extremes like you don't just drum you
drama on one of the largest kits there
is you don't just ride motorcycles you
ride 50,000 miles I'm gonna cream us
even when you describe your appetite for
reading to it seems like if we're ratios
appetite for reading like I guess is it
is that is that I guess is that what got
you where you are as a drummer I would
expect that it all comes down to a kind
of restlessness because I when people
talk about boredom for example I can
honestly say I've never been bored for a
second in my life but I've always found
another way not to be like if I have to
go to medical appointments I'm gonna
bring a book with me so that waiting is
not going to be a hardship but the early
days of touring when all that dead time
was hanging on me reading portable
useful you know nurturing all that stuff
so I think I come back you learn to
adapt to your own personality and and
the extremes to come in there to be I
wanted to read every book ever written
drumming wise my determination was more
important than talent early on I think
for most things you do have to have a
bit of a knack but I had to work so hard
to learn so many things but I was
relentless in terms of determination and
when traveling when I've got a day I am
tempted by what's the most excellent
thing I can do which might be way too
far way too long but I'm going to go for
that because it's the most excellent
thing I can do and with writing that it
just seems unstinting in the same way
because
I have a I just kind of know when I've
done my best on it and maybe an editor
can help make it better and maybe
somebody else could have written it
better but I have a good built-in sense
of this is the best I can do all I want
to do is have good scripts
however they have to manifest themselves
have you ever had an agenda have you
ever been I never had a mindset I never
have I never had like I'm I'm too
Restless
I couldn't here's what I uh I don't know
what I want to do but I know what I
don't want to do is that what I can
answer the question like that I don't
want to do the same type of movie over
and over again mm-hmm but I wouldn't
want to just be doing comedies I
wouldn't want to just be doing suspense
movies or action movies I would mean I
would that I mean I always want to like
mix it up